[Musique]
laissez moi vous parler aujourd'hui
d'une télé que vous ai déjà présenté en
tout début d'année c'était au csa las
vegas à l'époque on pouvait y aller
et bien je vous ai pas de cette toute
nouvelle télé de samsung qui s'appelle
the ce héros alors 0 c'est un nouveau
concept c'est ça me sauve et surtout
c'est une toute nouvelle ouverture ce
qui est super avec cette télé c'est
qu'elle va pouvoir bouger en fonction de
vos besoins je vous explique vous partez
d'un smartphone de préférence un
smartphone samsung parce que si vous
n'avez pas regardé hop là je bouge ça
bouge
si vous n'avez pas un smartphone samsung
expérience sera quand même bien moins
bonne bien moins intéressante le serait
ce qu'au niveau du partage et des
différentes fonctionnalités vous allez
pouvoir rapport avec il vous faut
l'application smart si samsung pour
pouvoir piloter tous vos objets de
samsung
ce qui est super avec cette télé c'est
qu'elle est conçue pour s'adapter à tous
vos contenus multimédias parce que oui
oui et oui et oui et vous le savez
aujourd'hui les contenus se consomme
aussi bien au format paysage qu'au
format portrait et pour ça il fallut une
télé qui s'adapte et pour ça regardez
vous n'avez qu'à venir pivoter votre
smartphone votre télé pivote ça c'est
très bien tout part d'un constat
aujourd'hui la façon de consommer le
contenu multimédia changer différents
fut une époque
la télé était le centre de l'univers
multimédia de votre maison aujourd'hui
c'est un peu différent ce qui est au
centre de l'univers multimédia et bien
c'est votre smartphone avec tout le
contenu en ligne qu'on aille on le voit
avec les plateformes qui se développe de
plus en plus il ya youtube netflix nay
canal disney company tout aujourd'hui et
ici sur votre smartphone donc l'idée de
créer une série qui va s'adapter à ce
que votre diffuser votre smartphone
paraît assez logique et assez malin en
finale au delà même de la prouesse
technologique on va pouvoir avoir avec
ce produit c'est juste un écran qui
pivote en fait un qui va pouvoir se
connecter s'adapte est une télé
connectée intelligente qui va s'adapter
au format au delà de ce côté un petit
peu what the fuck de la technologie est
bien ce que ça montre surtout c'est les
bouleversements qu on est en train
d'avoir et qui vont continuer à arriver
dans les années à venir les
bouleversements au niveau de tous nos
appareils domestiques
le smartphone la télé on voit qu'une
marques comme samsung est une marque et
moteur en innovation vient d'innover une
fois de plus sur ce type au logis de
produits samsung innove bien évidemment
sur les smartphones on l'a vu notamment
avec le galaxy folle qui est un
smartphone qui se plie on le voit avec
les télés qui pivote tout bouge to
change et ça c'est vraiment intéressant
et ça montre vraiment le début d'une
nouvelle ère alors non pas vous allez
avoir chez vous d'été l'équipement de
tous les côtés parce que je suis pas
convaincu que ce soit un produit qui se
vend beaucoup mais par contre je suis
convaincu que ce produit là ils ont
quelque chose de très fort et très
intéressants sont tous les
bouleversements et je vous dis une fois
de plus avec votre smartphone au centre
écosystèmes et ça c'est très intéressant
pour regarder côté purement
technologique on a essayé une grande
télé à la verticale avec un écran de 43
pouces 3840 pas 2160 pixels
quantum hdr à jeudi un avis plus on a
ici une dalle culêtre d'affaires de
l'umps kyling en 4k savoir tout-va
contenu vous allez diffusée depuis votre
smartphone en 1080p et bien il va vous
montez la qualité jusqu'à quatre cas
technologique d'apps kyling c'est connu
il ya plein de technos sont étalés de
samsung est celle ci ne déroge pas à la
règle
vous avez notamment l'adaptative
pictures c'est à dire que l'image de
votre téléviseur va s'adapter à la
luminosité ambiante de votre pièce est à
dire que pour vous avez lumière dans
votre pièce est plus à luminosité bien
monté sur l'écran est par contre quand
vous en avez un petit peu moins eh bien
il va diminuer ici pour avoir un confort
de visionnage maximale juste une
solution bas vous avez des enceintes 60
watts vous avez 1 4 point dolby digital
plus avec en plus une techno qui
intéressant qui s'appelle la va en fait
c'est l'amplificateur vocale ça va
détecter les sons ambiants dans une
pièce si vous aurez par exemple beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de bruit ça va venir
augmenter le volume des voix c'est à
dire les fréquences médium pour plus de
compréhension vous pouvez soit bien la
piloter directement à votre petite
télécommande là c'est extrêmement
minimaliste
vous avez un bouton ici pour venir à la
faire pivoter et là je sors tyson de
façon très très très standard c'est à
dire que je vais avoir tout mes menus
mes réglages prime apple tv ocs enfin à
prévoir en fonction des abonnements que
j'ai j'ai également youtube j'ai tous
mes galerie smart 6
ça c'est un tyson vraiment vraiment
standards comme ont pu le connaître ça
marche bien c'est pratique vous avez vos
différentes à pic pour télécharger vos
films pouvaient voir le monde enfin
voilà sur le principe c'est tyson c'est
cool et ça marche bien mais l'homme
s'est dit extrêmement intéressant c'est
qu'on devrait pouvoir venir le connecter
avec un smartphone de samsung louis
samsung d'un point de vue purement
logicielle parce qu'il fait partie de
l'écosystème samsung même secoué venir
castet du contenu depuis un autre
smartphone android ou encore avec
airplanes d'apple vous pouvez le faire
depuis ios mais l'expérience maximale
vraiment serein quant aux smartphones de
samsung cette télé il faut l'acheter si
vous avez un smartphone de samsung si
vous n'avez pas un smartphone de samsung
il ya un peu moins d'intérêt pour vous
connecter sur un smartphone de samsung
il faut venir ici dans smartview que
vous venez activé vous n'avez plus qu'à
la sélectionner et là vous allez avoir
un vrai mirroring de votre smartphone
directement sur votre télé ça c'est
vraiment très très sympa lors d'un petit
délai de latence donc si vous voulez
jouer à des jeux en regardant uniquement
votre écran eh bien vous risquez de
souffrir un petit peu mais par contre
pour casser du contenu ça marche vrai
bien que ce soit du contenu sur netflix
vous allez consulter votre il toque
extrêmement facilement d'ailleurs je
quitte à me suivre aux tic toc
monsieur greu nîmes ont rejoint n'y a
pas un truc très sympa pouvez également
naviguer dans instagram
regardez toutes les stories que vous
voulez en somme c'est une télé qui vient
s'adapter à votre façon de vivre et non
pas la verse alors par contre il faut
lui trouver un petit peu de place parce
qu'elle est reposé sur un pied
directement au sol
il vous faut un tout petit peu de
dégagement à côté pour qu'elles puissent
pivoter très facilement pour voir où
sont les collecter qu'il faut passer par
l'arrière hdmi usb irc on va retrouver
ici les grands standards
je ne crois pas que ce soit la télé du
futur mais ce que ça monte ses quatre
vrais changements dans nos modes de
consommation est notamment liée à tout
l'univers multimédia et que des
fabricants comme samsung s'y intéressent
avec des télés pivotante non vraiment
que tout cet écosystème est en train de
se réinventer une fois de plus cette
télé je ne suis pas persuadé qu'elle
soit faite pour tout le monde
probablement pour des personnes qui
consomment vraiment du contenu dans un
sens ou dans un autre
et pour qui une télé sera une extension
de leur smartphone pour les autres je ne
suis pas nécessairement sûr qu'elle soit
faite pour vous surtout qu'elle coûte
quand même le tarif de 1499 euros
oui une innovation ça se paye c'est
intéressant après la dalle et qualité qu
led samsung ça marche bien a vous de me
dire nathan vous ce que vous en pensez
en bas en commentaire moi je trouve ça
suffisamment intéressant non pas tant
pour le produit parce qu'une fois de
plus je pense pas qu'on retrouve dans
tous les foyers
mais par contre ce que je trouve
intéressant c'est de voir la technologie
de quelle manière industrielle comme
samsung va à l'avant de tous ces
changements s'adaptent et proposent des
innovations qui sont vraiment
différentes et différenciante moi ce que
vous en pensez vous en bas en
commentaire est ce que cette télé
pourrait vous intéresser au oui/non quoi
comment je suis pas rentrer plus dans
les détails au niveau de ce téléviseur
parce que je ne pense pas que vous
alliez vous l'acheter mais en tout cas
je trouve que l'idée vraiment là est
très très chaude mais ce que vous en
pensez en bas en commentaires qu'on ne
trouve extrêmement rapidement pour
parler de samsung est ailleurs le
smartphone que j'ai pris pour faire la
démo c'est le samsung galaxy à 41
dites moi si vous voulez qu'on en parle
je n'ai pas encore parlé sur la chaîne
est ce que vous voulez qu'on se fasse un
test de ce smartphone est ce qui lui
aurait potentiellement vous intéressez
dit le mât et en fonction de vos
réponses ou sortir un test plus ou moins
rapidement sur ce nous embrasser tel
monsieur groupe et à très bientôt et
bisous quelqu'un
[Musique]
magath absents
je ne veux pas